joining us right here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line to tell us
about that one time that uh belichick
kicked vinatari in practice
uh is willie mcginnis how are you will
are you there
i am how are you guys that was a that
was a strange time right when belichick
just went up and kicked vinatari and
said why don't you make more kicks that
happened right back in the day you know
what's funny man that actually happened
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
uh
yeah it wasn't belichick though it was
part sales and he used to do some little
funny things to adam to try to throw him
off come on like before he kicked phil
goes
and uh
you know he would go up throw grass in
front of him
kick the dirt in front of him do little
stuff to kind of throw him off before it
still goes because we would always have
something pending on the long field goal
in practice you know yeah whether it was
time off no meeting or whatever but
it was in a loving way i don't i don't i
don't think it was anything
any harm meant to it was just
a distraction i would say and try to
throw him off because you know i guess
you just gotta in some way shape or form
uh you know
make uh adversity part of practice
because that's what's gonna happen when
when real games happen so that's that's
stuff i've heard about from coaching all
this other stuff that that is coming out
of jacksonville through our colleague
tom pelissera over the weekend and then
obviously in the months before it and
then this past
couple of 24 hours that led to urban
meyer's firing i'll give you the floor
willie mcginnis what do you think about
all of this
when you asked as i am
not being in the building um i'm sure
there's things that go on and i'm sure
there's a lot of other things that are
probably surfaced but i think there's a
code of conduct that you gotta you know
represent yourself in a certain way and
i think that's what you know uh mr khan
was talking about when
after the bar incident happened he said
you know i expect you to hold yourself
and be accountable you know and
represent the organization the team
yourself in a certain light
and
i think when you're not winning games
rich
when
things are surfacing like that people in
the building are not happy
uh when you when you when you possibly
have lost the locker room i can't say
that's what happened but if you possibly
have have lost the locker room in your
voice
uh
no longer uh
happens and the players are not
following you
it's it's bad it's bad and it's hard to
continue to move on
um this way
and when you start
to factor in all the different things
that were happening
on top of not winning football games
it pretty much makes it tough to move to
continue on the way you have been
well let me just ask this question um
willie because you know
was there a time before brady became
brady in 2001 in that 2000 season
um when
it was difficult to buy what belichick
might have been selling in the manner in
which he was selling it because
he had yet to win anything and parcells
was parcels was that
was there ever a moment where the
patriot way might have been
you know up in the air before it was
fully formed
willie did that belichick's first year i
think we went what five and 11. we went
six and ten whatever the record was
uh but we were losing a lot of really
really close games and we we were
competing and i think
as a mature veteran or a guy in the
locker room you understand
a rebuild and when things are changing
and changing of the guard
you got to be able to implement a system
implement players that believe in a
system that fit what you're trying to do
and you know belichick made it clear
that
he was going to keep a certain type of
player
um that fit that and outside of that he
was going to build through the draft and
free agency to make up
you know the nucleus of what he wanted
as a team
so
we bought into that because he was on
that staff before
we knew he had success
you know with the giants and he also had
success in cleveland you know i played
against them in cleveland uh they beat
us in the playoffs so
it takes time but it also you have to
see things working
players have to buy in they got to
believe
um you know the preparation the hard
work everything that goes into it you
got to see the fruit of the labor
and i think although we didn't have a
great record we were losing close games
on little things that we can fix and
change
so after the season i was the biggest
advocate going out there guys that were
free agents like roman pfeiffer that i
worked out with and telling them look
man you're a free agent coming to new
england we got something special cooking
trust me man we're going to be good and
he's like man your record wasn't good i
might want to stay home play for the
raiders whatever the case may be
but he finally listened to me and his
agent reached out and he had a
conversation and it was the best thing
that ever happened to his career you
know he won multiple super bowls the
very next year we went in the super bowl
mode and all those guys
that
listened and believed were a part of
that and made it special
you know so i think there's an
opportunity if the message is right if
things are moving in the right direction
if if the atmosphere is clear if the
players um can buy into that
i i i do think you don't have to have a
winning record to get things turned
around
yeah brockman read him those numbers to
refresh his man yeah so 5 and 11 in 2000
but nine of the losses by one score nine
to the 11 by one scorer there you go one
score so how often is it though in the
nfl where game over your your team
that's successful which you've been on
more than most and then the other team
that's not
you know towards the end of the season
comes up and says you have no idea
what's going on over here and they
unburden themselves to you after a game
how often does that happen in the nfl a
lot
it's a lot like i talk to a lot of
players across the lake now and i
and you know my relationship with those
guys are special so i don't want to blow
anybody up of course
but there's teams that are losing now
and i talked to some of the players and
they're like
we have no idea what's going on you got
guys that you know going in different
directions the coaches are all over the
place like it's it's not a team
you know i was a part of that in
cleveland
you know from my personal experience you
had a small group of guys that wanted to
win that was doing everything they
possibly could do um to win football
games other guys are going out partying
wouldn't study wouldn't go to film
coming into meetings late you know
we get beat by 25 points they go out and
party that night the losses didn't mean
anything to him it's it's evident
and we had a great coach who come from
the winning you know winning background
and romeo cornell he knew how to win
it's just we didn't have enough mature
guys to buy into it
you know and you know he was he was
handcuffed by the gm
at the time where he couldn't go out and
just grab those type of players that he
wanted to bring in because he didn't
have the power to do that
so
you know there's a lot of things that
factor into it rich but the guys in the
locker room know
you know the coaches know and if they're
not all buying in the guys are talking
behind each other's back
if the coaches ain't on the same page
and there's no cohesiveness and the guys
aren't together and the message you know
isn't fluid throughout the building
everybody's on the same page it's not
gonna work it's just not you can have
the best system in the world whatever it
is if the players don't buy into it
it's not gonna work at all
let me get us my colleague from the nfl
network here uh on the rich eisen show
three-time super bowl champion all right
anybody who attempts to ask belichick
does 2021 have any echoes of 2001 to you
at all is going to get the answer of
well i'm just trying to win this game
this week i'm just moving on to this
snap we're moving on to whatever
cincinnati might be even though
that doesn't mean they're coming off a
loss because that hasn't happened in
quite some time but i'll ask you do you
think he's sitting there thinking
there's some echoes of 2001 going on
right here when he's sitting back i
think he's the best at pushing forward
i think he also is the best at
um recalling what it took that year when
you got a young quarterback that
doesn't have a lot of experience but has
the talent
that won't lose you football games
because he plays well within the system
and you can put him in position to play
at a high level with the running game
high percentage throws play action which
all those things you see from mac jones
you saw from tom brady
and a great defense and great special
teams that gives this offense multiple
opportunities because they turn the ball
over and they give you great field
position and special teams
all those things our name were the same
makeup we had in 2001 if you look at
that team we didn't need the quarterback
to go out and throw for 400 yards a game
we had a running game
we had
a really good coordinators that knew how
to put him in position he did not turn
the football over
you know good decision maker
put his team in the best situation to
win football games the defense went out
there that was our foundation we took
the ball away
you know we didn't give up a lot of
points
guess what they're number one in the
league at points they're only giving up
10 points a game they're one of the top
teams in turnovers and get after the
quarterback so all those things
mirror each other from that season of
this season may not say it but if you're
looking at it and if you're trying to
navigate the waters now in the league
and play a certain way
um
it's kind of identical
yeah i guess the only thing that's
missing is that the other quarterback in
the equation that year was still there
and as a matter of fact drew bledsoe won
the afc championship game that day when
brady got hurt and the other quarterback
in this equation got cut prior to the
season i mean other than that the
similarities to me are quite
eerie and that year it was all like yeah
he's doing so great that's terrific
that's great uh i mean you know are they
going to really make the playoffs then
you know you won your last four games of
the regular season and you make the
playoffs yeah but is he going to really
win this playoff game in the snow yeah
is he going to really go and do this one
and then and even all the way down the
super bowl john madden's like yeah they
got to take a knee they're not going to
go try and win the game right here i
mean until
we kept saying it over and over again
until the confetti came down and tom had
his hands on his head and you were you
were you were celebrating you know and
i'm wondering if the same thing's
happening right now in front of me
underdog all the way to the end rich you
know and it took a lot of special things
to happen that year you know there are a
lot of there are a lot of things in
place
a lot of motivation
you know um a big motivation for us that
year was 9 11 as well
that made us want to be a team
foot team you know really taught us what
team or over individualism was we wanted
to do something special you know for all
those that have fallen and risked their
lives in that situation you know our
quarterback coach you know have passed
away
there's a lot of underlying things that
have motivated and and came together to
to to really give us what we needed to
go forward and it was just a special
year um so i'm saying it's not a quite
the duplication right of what it was but
when you look at the team and
and and the situation they're in and the
opportunity that they have
they're right in line with it you know
they're right in line with it it's just
how they play the game and what they do
with how these coaches do a a fantastic
job of putting them in position and
knowing their personnel knowing what
they have and how they have to play
and i was
that was that was
you can look at the bills game this is
how we have to play
we're not trying to be anybody else or
do anything else this is what we do
and i think that's why the patriot way
was created because it's always been
about what this team organization needs
to do to win games and not try to follow
what everybody else around the league is
doing yeah especially against
against a specific opponent whose
weakness might be this and it's
different than the weakness of the team
we just beat the week before so we'll
just change what we need to do with the
same personnel to go face the other
team's weakness and uh it's really
unbelievable it really
really is and and now you know
it kind of looks really like you know
the football gods want the patriots to
face tom brady you know like it kind of
feels that way
to me willie
who do you root for william does that
happen
don't put him in that position chris
come on really now no i root for i i
i i root for tom no matter what and i
root for my patriots no matter what so
i'll just sit that one out
test it out if the stuff if the stars
align
you know i'm i'm i'm a patriot
until
until i go always always and the funny
thing is no matter who's playing in the
super bowl i always root for the afc
because i was the afc guy
um
but if the patriots are in i'm gonna
support them
uh but i got it i got a call i gotta
call it like i see it though like if i
see match-up problems or things that are
offshore whatever the case may be i'm
not going to change and lose my
credibility when it comes to my amount
good for you when it comes to that yes
but i always root for my brother tom
and i'm i'm a patriot for life so i'm
always going to root for the patriots i
got to tell you willie before i let you
go uh uh a quote that he gave to sports
illustrated when he won rightfully
sports person of the year um
when he said that winning is now more of
a relief to him than anything else that
kind of that gave me a little bit of
pause like
you know like that that's what you hear
when you when when people start thinking
about the end you know i'm wondering
what you think of when he's when you
hear the quote of like when we lose it's
depressing when we win it's a relief not
like the joy the happiness it's a relief
what do you think he means by that
what's going on between his temples
if you can i think there's so much that
goes into winning
um
and whether it's doubt whether it's the
work you have to put in or there's
things you have to overcome
it is kind of like a relief you know um
the fun part is sundays
a lot of people don't see all the work
that goes into it before you get there
and that's where all the work happens
the the
the sunday is the kind of the relief
relax let it all go let's party let's
have a great time
that's your reward for everything that
you put into it so
i think from a guy like that that
expects so much of itself
at
during practice whatever it is he's
always doing more and
to get that win it's just like
a relief
the pressure's off you you've
accomplished okay now
you got to forget about that enjoy for a
quick minute and start all over again
so it's it's about guys with his stature
on that level putting so much pressure
on yourself in every single way and
listening to what everybody is saying
and trying to maintain a certain amount
of focus
and play at a high level
at what people say you couldn't do
but five years ago said you should have
probably retired now you're still
you know at the top of your game
and
maintaining that i just think that's
what it is rich
all right willie thanks the call good to
see you whenever i run into you the
halls of nfl network love to have you
here in person and i look forward to
speaking with you again thanks for the
time willie greatly appreciate it you
got it man love you guys right back i
love you too that's really the guinness
everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here